hello everyone and welcome to another
really wild game from round four
of the 2021 tata steel chess tournament
it's ariantari versus alireza firuja and
this game features two very special post
video moments so let's just dive
straight into it
and reach them as soon as possible so
tari with the white pieces opens with e4
and firusa goes for the karo khan that's
not a karo khan
c6 we have d4 d5 and now e5 the advanced
variation
against the karo khan bishop to f5 and
now
knight to f3 so as the bishop has been
developed you no longer need to
keep an eye on these light squares so
you close the position with e6 and now
the bishop is here
white may choose to attack it at some
point but also can just continue
developing so bishop to e2 by tari
and knight the e7 preparing to bring
this knight over to g6 with c3
uh by tari and firuja goes for knight to
g6 as planned
castles and now knight to d7 continuing
development
uh and here knight to f unites the e1
knight to e1 already with a deadly
threat of g4 g4 would strap the bishop
on f5
so alireza needs to figure out how to
defend it he defends it with h5
blocking g4 and here bishop to e3
now this position has been reached
before c5 is the known move here
uh h4 is a known move here but here
alersa goes for queen to b6 and queen to
b6 is a new move in the position
so already as of move nine we have a
completely new game
uh here tari uh as the b2 point is under
attack he defends it he pushes it to b3
and now alerza goes for f6 which is
very interesting as his own king is
still in the center of the board and
he's opening up the center
uh but if it works uh you know why not
and one of the reasons the pawn was
pushed to h4
in the other games that were played is
because the pawn is under attack so
you might want to attend to that but
alireza doesn't alireza just gives it up
and uh tarry grabs it with bishop
captures on h5 now pinning the knight
here
and while you could castle alireza says
uh there's always time for that with
f captures on e5 and now what do you
play here uh well there's the safe
option
bishop captures on g6 and we're gonna
show this because it's safe
for example captures captures and now
captures an e5
attacking the queen and after queen to
c7 with a double attack here you can
defend
it with f4 and it's uh it's basically
the kind of position that alireza wanted
to play
uh he will he will castle queen side
he's gonna have a nice h open h file uh
for
for attacking the white king and this is
what he was going for
but tadi says nope we're gonna go for
the incredibly sharp
g4 and now alireza's bishop here
has nowhere to go uh if you go to e4
it's not a problem
uh the bishop can be further attacked
with the knights to d2 with f3
and so on uh so here uh we have the
absolute best move by alexa
rook captures on h5 so now uh you have
to capture the rook if you capture the
bishop then
rook captures it you don't really gain
anything by this
so g captures on h5 and knight to f
for now uh it's an incredibly strong
night so
uh we'll see what happens with it uh d
captures on e5 now with a double attack
on the queen and on the knight here
and before you move the queen you have
to play knight to h3 check it is the
only good move here for alireza
so he goes for it knights h3 with check
king to g2 and now uh as the queen is
still under attack you can either
move the queen the block with bishop to
c5 or play the move alireza played which
is c5
at some point you want to play queen to
c6 put your queen on the same diagonal
as the king and advance this pawn to d4
if white allows it of course so here f4
strengthening this uh central e5 pawn
and here uh
queen to c6 by already so he's not in
rush to castle
uh there's always time for that he wants
to now take advantage of this and get
this d4 move in so here knights to f3
preventing
any checks and only now alireza castles
and now
it's a question how do you play this who
is better here can white attack and
black attack
what's happening here uh the the white
king is here
very very bravely placed on g2 so
let's see how how tar he deals with this
he plays knight b to d2
and now uh can already somehow take
advantage of this
it's still very much too early for d4
because the
square is defended uh three times well
twice actually because the knight is
pinned
but it doesn't seem to bring anything uh
to alireza so first
knight the b6 and now uh here
king to g3 seems to be like an
incredibly strong move but king to g3
is a disgusting engine move so we're not
going to look into that
but you know just a side stepping the
light square diagonal and
claiming that you are very safe on g3
but okay here
targos for queen to e1 and
now now we have bishop to e7 here
alireza
could go for the instant d4 for example
after c
captures now knight d5 and here
everything is under attack
this is attacked twice there's pressure
on the bishop maybe bishop to d3 is an
idea
so uh really really a lot of wonderful
things happening here
uh the problem is after this rook the c1
could quite
do anything about this but it doesn't
seem so after king b8
uh alireza's king seems to be very safe
uh but instead after queen to e1 we have
bishop to e7 first by alireza
so first developing the bishop he can
always play this d4 move
and now rook to c1 so the rook is
already placed here but now alareza
plays d for nonetheless and it seems
like
this this is not an issue for him so
here
c captures on d4 and now knight to d5
the knight
is brought into the attack the f4 pawn
is attacked twice
so knights the c4 going after that d6
square and now knight
d captures an f4 with check bishop
captures uh although you could just go
king to h1 but okay bishop captures
knight captures with
check and now king to g1
uh sidestepping check and also getting
away from this diagonal and here
uh we have bishop to g4 rook captures on
d4
seems to be another very interesting
move for alireza because the
rook cannot be captured because queen to
g2 will be checkmate the knight covers
the g2 square
uh but instead alireza goes for this
very nice bishop to g4
first pins the knight as now uh the
knight is attacked twice uh i say pin
because the knight cannot move
because of checkmate so here rook to c3
adding another defender to the knight
and only now rook
captures on d4 and now what do you play
here tari went for knight the d6 with
check but first you just ignores in king
to b8
and now queen to e3 a very nice uh
centralizing move with the queen asking
what do you want to do here
so here alireza played bishop to g5
but now there's really nothing to be
done here this is just a
a winning position for white but it's
very hard
to it's very hard to pinpoint why it's a
winning position
for white so we've reached our first uh
beautiful moment of the game
where you can feel you know feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
absolute best move for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations
as this is uh this is such a weird move
to play that
i don't know if any of you found it if
you have then truly congratulations
and uh for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show the only winning move for
white is king to h1
and this is just stupid uh the
you know uh going under the mask of the
black queen what what the what does this
move do
well in order to tell you what it does
uh first i'm going to show you what
happens if you don't play it and then
it's going to be pretty much
self-explanatory
for example if you play something like
queen captures on d4
which is uh the threat you actually want
to play queen captures on d4
hoping for pawn captures and then you
win the black queen
problem is knight the e to check wins
the queen
so you you get your queen nicely forked
and
that's just game black wins the wins the
game so
in order to avoid this and to be able to
take advantage of this threat you just
sidestep the check king to h1 now
there's no knife to e2 with
check and this row cannot move next move
you're gonna capture it uh
if if you move it just captures on c5
queen moves anywhere
uh rook the c8 is checkmate so of course
black cannot allow this so here
there would be a very few moves black
and played there is a fun line bishop to
h3 going for
bishop to g2 with check but just
captures on d4
bishop g to check or rather we could
even go bishop captures on f1
grabbing that rook but now queen to e4
and now you have to trade queens because
the bishop on g5 is hanging
and after captures captures the bishop
is still hanging you have to go back
and now black has this problem that
white is up the exchange and white's
position is is very much winning
so this is what toddy had in the
position after all it is i played bishop
to g5
however tari went for rook captures on
c5 i have
i have to mention they were both
extremely low on time here so you have
to play
incredibly fast it's only moved 28 and
they need more 40 to reach time control
to be granted those additional 40
minutes
and now of course if you move the queen
somewhere weird rook the c8 will be
checkmate so
you have to play something very very
precise here
but there is only of course one good
move queen captures on c5
point being that rook the c1 does not
equal
checkmate because the black queen will
not move black will just play rook to d1
check and now uh you've exposed your
queen to the attack and this is just
lost for white for example if king f2
you just go rook to d2 with check the
queen cannot capture the queen is pinned
you have to capture with the knight but
now bishop to h for
check and the king can no longer defend
the white queen if you go to
the g1 then the queen can just be
captured but if you go to f1
then there's an even nicer queen
captures on c1 check the king has
nowhere to go you have to block with the
queen and then queenie one is checkmate
so this is uh the kind of stuff that's
happening here
so after this queen captures on c5 uh uh
alireza
sorry tardy went for knight captures on
g5 but
even this isn't enough uh so feel free
to pause the video and
win this game for alireza as now black
is completely winning
so uh while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations as
i can't decide if this move is
uh more difficult to find or the
previous king to h1 they're kind of both
difficult to find so if you found either
of them
you know truly congratulations you you
are an
exceptional uh finder of great moves
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show uh it's not
uh knight the e2 with check this is what
alireza played in the game we're gonna
get back to that
the move that actually wins is bishop to
e2
uh you have to play something because
your your knight is under attack here
uh and uh well you have to play
something so here all it is i moved the
knight with chug but rather
uh bishop to e2 would have been better
uh you're attacking the rook and you're
asking white what do you play here
so if white doesn't want to lose
material white needs to
move the knight there there are no
discoveries there are no checks uh so
you can take advantage of this uh
you know queen action here uh so after
rook to e1
defending now you play rook to d1 a
temporary a beautiful temporary queen
sacrifice
should have been played and now you
don't really have a good move here
uh whatever you play you either lose
material so you have to capture the
queen only move
queen captures on c5 and now rook
captures on e1 with
check leaving the white king with only
one option and that is king to f2
running into this wonderful fork so
knight to d3 with
check not only forking the king and the
queen but also guarding your rook on e1
so the king cannot capture king e3 now
knight captures on c5
and now you are completely winning it's
not
that obvious because white can still win
back the piece king d2
rook to g1 uh hoping for
winning some material uh but also you
could go for
rook to g1 attacking the knight on g5 so
after the knight moves
knight h3 attacking the rook rook the a1
now
you just capture it or you could go even
for rook to a1
even better you you have to give up the
bishop so it's not a problem
king captures on e2 you're just going to
grab here with check king to f3
now you can grab this pawn or or you can
go rook to b2 to grab this pawn to
create two connected past pawns here on
the queen side
and here we could we can just play it
out at it as it is very fun
uh knight to e8 or going for this spawn
hoping to create a pass pawn here rook
captures on b3 with
czech king g4 and now a5 and now the the
race is
somewhat beautiful knight captures on g7
a4 h6 and now uh you have to take care
of
this pawn so knight to d7 uh the thing
is if the pawn is pushed just knight
captures with
check followed by knight f7 guards uh
the the h8 sorry the h8 square
so here knights the g5 for example uh
but now
a3 h7 and now knight captures an e5 with
check king the h5 and now the beautiful
rook to h3 with
check taking uh getting this knight away
from the
uh the df7 square now you have to move
it as the knight is controlling the f7
square you want to get your own knight
here
or if the uh the king moves but the king
cannot move as the knight covers the
square so only move
now knight to f7 blocking the queening
square king g6
knight tonight delivers check king to h6
and now you are queening your pawn uh
white is just too slow captures a one
queen and that's just it black wins
so this is a a long line but it's not a
force line i just showed it because it's
super fun but
if you find bishop to e2 then all of the
lines are winning after bishop to e2 but
here
alireza played knights the e2 with check
and here after king to g2 by ahri uh the
both of them agreed to a draw the
position is in fact
a little bit better for white here or
draw you know is between draw and maybe
white is a little bit better
uh but uh ari was around a minute on the
clock
when the game ended in a draw uh so of
course uh you know
uh he was very happy with it uh you know
as alireza is much higher ready than him
uh so you know
very good stuff uh but yeah uh here it
basically is a draw because
after black continues with something
like queen d5 check you can block it
knight g to e4 and now if uh there's
another attacker added here
we could see queen captures on e2 bishop
captures an e2 with check and now came
to g1
and now uh it's just uh even better
position for white there's no way to
continue the attack the
white king is very safe you cannot play
a rook d2 because the bishop is hanging
and if you try something like bishop to
d3 to win material then
rook the e f8 with czech king to c7
and the queen to f3 now again forces a
queen trade
if you move the queen then just captures
here uh so we would see maybe a captures
captures and now
we we continue this game white is up a
pawn it's a better position for white
but yeah uh after king to g2 as uh thai
was extremely low on time i think he was
also very happy with the draw here
uh it was in this position that the
players agreed to a draw
so a fair result uh like we said uh in
that position after bishop to g5 came to
h1 by tari
bringing him uh uh uh well if not
winning
uh winning with perfect play but but
that means winning
a winning advantage and also same for
alireza
after this knights the g5 move he had
bishop to e2 so
both of them had uh uh you know chances
in this game
but in the end even classical time
control was not enough to calculate this
very very uh complicated game
uh so i hope you guys enjoyed it uh
that's the game i would like to thank
dv dynamo uh ciaran farah luis madison
omar dasa and
ryan urban for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and uh i will see you soon continuing
the coverage of the tata still 2021
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and uh whatever else happens in the
chess world so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day